[Music]
this ring first off like this blinded me
when I just saw you welcome her he's
here with me yeah we took some pictures
on the red carpet this is our first
premiere together all right are you
helping at all with the money planner
you like that stuff and I do not want to
help at all so he's gonna take care of
it you're marrying a guy who actually
has a lot of experience at funny wedding
so you're set he's the best he just
finished his biggest wedding in his
career three days ago so yeah it's Tina
Turner's wedding Chelsea Clinton's
wedding Sofia Vergara who I love guess
what's your bachelor party gonna be like
I've even thought about your master
party I think we're gonna have one we've
been I've been a bachelor for a long
time now so they were just gonna have
you know like one in the movies a little
wine some cheese
yeah the entire group would you trust to
plan your bachelor party
Zoey in a second am I saying her why she
seems like a party animal
she's so chilled so easygoing and she
just knows her way around everything
like Scarlett cuz she could get us on
like a yacht but yeah you never know
[Music]
you